let's talk about Donald Trump we got
this uh this tweet from Kyle Chaney says
Donald Trump swore in court yesterday he
would not attempt to influence or
intimidate Witnesses retaliate against
anyone or in any other way attempt to
obstruct the administration of justice
quote are you prepared to comply the
Magistrate Judge asked yes Trump replied
and then uh Trump posted on Truth social
I guess if you go after me I'm coming
after you and now all these people are
calling for Trump to be locked up isn't
there some movie where it's like set a
threat and they're like no it's a
promise like maybe he's not threatening
them maybe he's just letting people know
what his plan is
the question I suppose is uh we asked it
last night now that we got you guys here
why didn't they not remand Trump to
custody because they wanted him to do
something like this can you take this
but this is now the pretext for them to
remain into custody they could have just
done it well even if you're a president
you get arrested don't you still get
secret service so maybe that's why
because it's just the logistics it's
like how are we going to put them I'm
saying if these charges were real if
they actually were concerned Trump tried
to overthrow the government they would
not let him go they'd be like bro look
at the j6ers you you you trespass on
Capitol grounds they lock you up for two
years Donald Trump is accused of making
the whole thing happen they're like ah
you're free to go buddy here's your
passport back there's your jumbo jet
have a good day plan yeah they don't
actually believe these charges well I
think that's just it and that like the
entire thing is political and I mean his
defense is going to be and his defense
for the next you know year is going to
be that it's political speech he's
campaigning this is a campaign promise
essentially uh because he could just
turn around and say I'm going to drain
the swamp or you know Purge the Deep
State type of thing well that's
campaigning so I wonder if Trump did
this on purpose hoping that they
actually use that his pretext to bring
him back because then it goes to scotus
and scottis throws the whole thing out
that's that would be actually be really
smart because I mean it's First
Amendment like honestly if this goes to
scotus like everybody is saying that
yeah everybody is saying that it's oh
this is thrown out people I don't think
people realize there is no there is no
path this can take other than it gonna
be wild oh yeah yeah oh yeah because I
understood man because at the very least
this has to go to the Supreme Court a
former sitting president criminally
charged there's too many questions
there's going to be Appeals
and then how does it get handled we're
looking at the the apex of the U.S
constitutional Branch Powers each
Branch's Authority where where is that
limit how quickly do you think it'll get
to the Supreme Court though well I don't
know dershowitz said he'll get convicted
first and then it'll go to Supreme Court
but but to your point maybe this would
fast track it like if he literally you
know got remanded like I I feel like
that you know and Trump needs to be
romantic in such a way that is not
clear-cut if Trump literally goes to
Giuliani and is on camera berating him
then he's gonna have a hard time making
an argument if they try and remand it
for something like this now you've got
big questions to be asked the Supreme
Court about his right to campaign is
Free Speech correct and then they could
use that as a pretext to just throw the
whole thing out exactly yeah I think
it's going to be an uphill battle they
want to do anything they can to take
Trump out and I do think they're going
to be successful I am not trying to be
black pills or negative I just think
that Trump is going to have to
eventually and I hope that I hope I'm
wrong I think he's gonna have to
eventually either say I'm not gonna run
and then I think that that would set him
up to get a more lenient sentence I
think I mean I don't know how he gets
out of this if they're just going to
continue to just charge him and stuff
look at the polls man yeah the he's he's
beating Biden yeah yeah I know but that
doesn't mean that's only going to
encourage him to try to get him in jail
more but he could be president from jail
theoretically right yeah and he's like
pardon himself and if he gets convicted
they could take
him off the ballot and then a lot of
people will just vote R and they won't
even think twice about who's on the
ballot or not so much people write them
in it'll split the vote yup and then you
end up with Newsome as president I think
that's a strong possibility have you
ever have you guys heard my theory I
mentioned the past couple days no what
is it job uh Gavin Newsom is campaigning
with Joe Biden and Joe Biden has like a
heart attack or something Gavin Newsom
runs at full speed on the stage rolls up
his sleeves and does CPR and Biden and
that would be fun screams for help and
then what happens Biden either is okay
or incapacitated Gavin Newsom then does
every press round where they're like
tell us what it was like when you ran
out to save the president's life how do
you get Gavin Newsom above Joe Biden in
the polls above Kamala Harris how do you
replace Biden with Gavin Newsom how do
you replace him without overstepping or
insulting Kamala Harris and and you know
the woke crowd Gavin Newsom saving the
life of Joe Biden well Barack Obama even
said that if you need something
up I I think that was a quote then just
have Joe Biden be in charge of it I
think the humiliation ritual is coming
up or they're going to make him step
down something's going to come up with
Hunter I don't the reason I don't think
so is because that makes the whole party
look weak and it it there's a lot of
people who vote based on party not based
on person well and just to counter that
though actually it would make them look
like hey you know he was our president
and then he did something illegal and we
held him accountable so we're actually
the party of truth because we actually
go out there I mean that's what I think
they could they may do that I'm just
saying that the that's there's a net
negative there because now what they're
basically saying is we we begged you to
vote for the guy who turned out to be
more corrupt and did something illegal
whereas if Biden's exit is due to the
sacrifice yeah that and and then Gavin
will say something or they'll have like
a doctor say we've been warning the
president
to take it easy but he insisted on being
there for this country and then you've
got Gavin Newsom how do you get him in
the Press rounds this is how you do it
he saves the life and then they're like
Gavin Governor Newsom tell us what
happened and then he's like he's got a
tear in his eye and he's like I looked
at this man who have I looked I've
looked up to my whole life and I said
Joe we got you you ain't going anywhere
buddy
and and and you know I knew blah blah
like it's just it just writes itself you
think Avenues would be a good president
you need to be the best well Kamala
Harris Let's see how did you yes no no
hold on let me answer this yes if you
want to poop in the street all right
there you go how fast a lot of people
who do uh how fast is Hunter Biden's
trial moving in comparison to trumps
right now because it'd be interesting to
see who gets convicted first if I was
Hunter if I was like I'm serious if I
was Hunter I would just plead guilty and
get pardoned by my dad if I wasn't him
yeah you would think he would want this
to go wall Biden is definitely for sure
still enough I don't know but look look
the the plea agreement they had was the
deal with his dad they were like I bet
Joe was like Hunter we got to get
something we're gonna do this light
thing it's gonna be a few months of
probation then it's all gone washed away
we got your back and then the judge
sniffed out that hey there's broad
immunity in this agreement that
shouldn't be there it's unprecedented
and they're like uh the prosecutors are
like you're correct that's right uh and
then Hunter was like no way no way
they're gonna throw me under the bus the
whole thing's a scam what's weird though
is so if you notice like Kareen Jean
Pierre any time she's asked about Hunter
Biden at the white house uh she says I
can't comment it's a different matter or
whatever the one answer that she gave an
affirmative and 100 straightforward
answer was is Joe going to Pardon Hunter
and she just said no that's it she
answered that question she answered so
that that does show that they were
probably talking about it yeah
she needs a pardon him because his
charges are going to be oh yeah exactly
but but my point is she deferred every
other question except for that one so I
mean it came up and they were talking
about it behind the scenes so with with
Hunter Biden avoiding paying taxes it's
like accidental underpayment and slap on
the recharge with Trump you know having
having multiple years where different uh
accounting firms evaluate his properties
they're like this was intentional
manipulation of numbers to steal yep
it's always the worst interpretation oh
yeah well I'm all about holding our
politicians you know accountable and I
love government transparency but let's
be real a president is above the law I
mean they are a little bit Above the Law
they're they're you know they basically
you know kill people they decide to go
to war I just think that they're not a
normal person so they're setting a
precedent where they can put a
ex-president in jail it just makes our
country look bad it makes us look so bad
in my opinion it's like you know cutting
off your nose despite your face
yeah and also how the doj is under that
branch of government the executive
branch like it's like super weird how
now they are technically above the
president like asserting themselves it's
weird but I think the reality is
whichever whichever Branch the Deep
State the intelligence agencies can use
will have the most power at the time
like the idea that Congress was impeding
Donald Trump and they were going after
him without his investigations when
typically the executive branch has had
this ridiculous amount of power because
the power is really with the
intelligence agencies and they just use
whatever vehicle they need to well the
CIA and I think the FBI they also say
that they are the real ones in power
because the president changes every four
to eight years and they all stay in
exactly permanent government yeah the
Deep state it is real so what do you
guys think do you think where do you
think this goes
uh do you think that comes 2024 we all
cast our ballots and smile as we and
then when when one whichever fashion
gets elected the other faction smiles
and then waves American flags we all go
on the street and hug yeah that's
exactly what's going to happen no I
don't know I mean Kamala Harris what if
she gave a BJ to Mayor Willie Brown
together is that confirmed though it's
close enough and then she dated Montel
Williams I love that journalism over
there yeah
can you imagine close enough well I
don't ever claim to be a real journalist
but uh they had an affair I'm pretty
sure yeah they had an affair but you see
you're being a little too graphic here
come on you gotta okay
what's an affair I mean they had to do
the hippity dibbity come on
they weren't just well continues she
dated Montel Williams also she dated
Montel Williams as well and she was in
supposedly in a throuple she went to you
know a couple of his things and so she's
not qualified to be the president and I
think that that's kind of scaring them
is what are they going to do with
Camelot how are we going to put her you
know on the B team or how are we going
to get her yeah I think that's the
biggest obstacle for the Democratic
party right now what to do with Kamala
because I mean when Larry Elders on the
show he was saying like you will
completely isolate female black voters
which I don't know if they're enough to
tip the scales on the other hand that
goes against the cultural conversation
you've been leading for years here so
again I think that's why there was a
moment where everyone's like maybe
Michelle like maybe we can just Edge her
out but like again weird tokenism I I
don't think they know what to do I
personally think it's going to be
terminal illness route I think Joe will
announce he has a terminal illness and I
it's I mean I'm loathe to make
predictions on the internet right hello
uh because someone will wonder you know
someone will call me out on it but I I
think Trump will end up on the ballot I
can't say what's going to happen on his
legal team but I think the Republican
Party eventually will realize that like
if he continues on the way he is it
would be impossible to keep the trust of
their voters and have anyone else there
I just I don't see Trump beating Chris
Christie that's true Chris Christie's in
like Ukraine right like what is up with
all of these like Republican presidents
yeah making their visit to Ukraine like
I I don't understand I think they want
Vladimir zielinski to pass away so they
have another Franz Ferdinand so they can
start World War III could you imagine
because he's been so Joe zielinski's got
to be sweating bullets I feel like if
there's this because he's like you know
he goes to Nato and they're like here's
what we want you to do and he's like
okay but then he's got to know in the
back of his mind the NATO guys are
crossing their fingers hoping that Putin
takes him out so they can justify
expansion of War exactly right literally
like Franz Ferdinand starting World War
one I mean that's what they want they
need somebody to rally the troops and we
were joking about aliens earlier but
even Ronald Reagan said in his one of
his state of the unions the only way to
unite the worlds is if we had an
existential threat like an alien force
so I think it goes to that it's like um
they need something like him to die for
World War III to they need like that one
thing that just the straw that breaks
the camel's back thanks for watching
this clip clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time